[Musica]
meritiamo l'estinzione
A quanti di voi è mai capitato di
pensarlo almeno una volta per alzata di
mano alzata di mano non Vergognatevi non
siate timidi Beh devo dire una buona
metà di noi ed effettivamente è vero
certe volte vediamo delle immagini che
ci fanno pensare che l'estinzione possa
essere l'unica via d'uscita noi esseri
umani siamo dei parassiti ogni volta che
ci inseriamo in un luogo non possiamo
fare a meno di distruggerlo
ed effettivamente vedere certe cose ci
fa venire l'ansia
o meglio l'eco ansia la sensazione
generalizzata che le basi ecologiche
dell'esistenza siano in procinto di
crollare
pensate che nel 2021 uno studio
pubblicato su The lancet ha messo in
luce come addirittura un giovane su due
soffra di eco ansia e ben tre giovani su
quattro abbiano paura quando pensano al
proprio futuro
Ed effettivamente sono diverse le cause
che possono portare all'Eco ansia per
esempio quando si rimane vittime di un
disastro ambientale di un evento estremo
oppure quando ci sentiamo bombardati da
notizie negative sulla crisi climatica
ma secondo me il fattore predominante è
l'inazione
ovvero quando Vediamo che nonostante
tutti gli allarmi della comunità
scientifica
all'apparenza non la stia cambiando
se Poi allineazione aggiungiamo anche
quel piccolissimo dettaglio che qualcuno
di noi su un pianeta al collasso ci
dovrà vivere ancora per svariati decenni
Diciamo che il mix è letale
ed effettivamente Provate a
immaginarvelo avete 19 anni
vi siete appena diplomati
sono gli anni migliori no
e tra un mojito e l'altro venite a
sapere che siamo nel pieno di una crisi
climatica causata dal sistema economico
produttivo basato sull'utilizzo dei
combustibili fossili la comunità
scientifica però ci ha dato le
istruzioni ci ha dato un modo per
invertire la rotta eppure i governi a
livello globale non stanno facendo nulla
per affrontare il collasso climatico
E allora vedete Com'è possibile che non
facciano nulla e iniziate Voi iniziate
voi a provare a diffondere
consapevolezza e Cominciate a parlarne
con i vostri amici poi con i vostri
genitori e più vi confrontate con le
persone più vi rendete conto di quanto
la risposta più gettonata da parte degli
adulti sia
voi giovani siete la nostra speranza
ecco quando ci sentiamo dire voi giovani
siete la nostra speranza
Si deprimiamo perché per noi è come un
macigno che ci viene scaraventato
addosso e il peso della responsabilità è
semplicemente insostenibile a maggior
ragione se nella persona che ce lo dice
non Notiamo non vediamo quello stesso
desiderio di cambiare
perché questa è speranza passiva
è aspettarsi che siano gli altri a
risolvere i problemi al posto nostro
restare a guardare mentre il mondo
brucia
e la speranza passiva genera impotenza
quella stessa impotenza Tra l'altro che
i maggiori responsabili della crisi
climatica vogliono che proviamo così da
poter continuare indisturbati a emettere
CO2 a fare profitti e a mantenere il
business AS usual
non è un caso Infatti se nel 2019 il
capo dell'opec organizzazione dei paesi
esportatori di petrolio ha definito gli
attivisti per il clima come la più
grande minaccia per l'industria
petrolifera
che comunque è un merito che noi ci
rivendichiamo con orgoglio
Sì perché nel 2019 per la prima volta
una crescente mobilitazione di massa ha
messo in discussione con forza
l'economia fossile
quindi la speranza passiva genera
impotenza e l'impotenza potrebbe portare
a ciò che mi piace chiamare inattivismo
in attivismo è un po' la nostra comfort
zone è quella poltrona comoda e
accogliente dove noi ci sediamo e
all'improvviso Ci sentiamo al riparo da
ogni critica Dal di lì Noi non abbiamo
paura di niente non ci dobbiamo esporre
chiaramente sentiamo le notizie sappiamo
che c'è un problema Siamo preoccupati
per questo problema
ma non dobbiamo diventare parte della
soluzione e Dal di lì possiamo
addirittura permetterci Il privilegio di
pensare che in fondo meritiamo
l'estensione perché non c'è più nulla da
fare
Questo è un concetto molto dibattuto nel
mondo dell'attivismo tra le voci più
autorevoli che ne hanno parlato C'è
anche quella del climatologo Michael
Mann Non esattamente l'ultimo arrivato
in campo di ricerca climatica tant'è che
nel 1999 l'anno in cui sono nata io
pubblicò fu tra coloro che pubblicarono
il famoso grafico a mazza da Hockey
quello che per la prima volta nella
storia dimostrò in maniera
inequivocabile
l'impennata della temperatura media
globale Ecco Michael Mann sostiene che
nel dibattito sulla crisi climatica
ormai il problema Maggiore non sia più
il negazionismo climatico ormai chiunque
si accorgerebbe che c'è un problema
Semmai siamo entrati in una nuova fase
di negazionismo climatico il climate
domisem
ovvero quell'idea secondo cui ormai non
c'è più nulla da fare la crisi climatica
è irreversibile meritiamo l'estinzione
chiaramente questa idea non si è
sedimentata in noi a caso tutt'altro
Se ci pensate sempre più spesso sentiamo
dire come il riscaldamento globale sia
colpa nostra colpa di noi individui in
maniera indistinta
Ecco questo chiaramente non è del tutto
vero
quindi la crisi climatica è colpa di
nostri di noi individui Beh questo
Almeno è quello che sostengono le grandi
aziende che estraggono petrolio che
stanno finanziando campagna con Milioni
miliardi di dollari per convincerci che
sia così prendiamo per esempio una
famosissima campagna del 2004
un'azienda che estrae petrolio È
un'azienda Britannica
Ca è riuscita a convincerci che siamo
noi il problema
calcola la tua impronta sull'ambiente
e così noi abbiamo iniziato a guardare
alle nostre quattro tonnellate di CO2
che ogni individuo produce ogni anno in
media
e ci siamo dimenticati delle 14,5
milioni di tonnellate che questa stessa
azienda da sola produce in un solo anno
E questo perché chi inquina vuole che
molliamo non vuole che noi opponiamo
Resistenza non vuole che intralciamo i
suoi interessi e quindi sta mettendo in
campo campagne comunicative sempre più
subdole sempre più efficaci in modo che
noi ci auto convinciamo che nonostante
tutto il piccoli sforzi che noi possiamo
fare per ridurre le nostre missioni a
livello individuale alla fine tanto
Nulla cambierà tanto non serve a niente
e allora tanto vale estinguerci non c'è
più nulla da fare
e questo è un motore di inattivismo
Eppure ci sarebbero ancora così tante
cose che potremmo fare ancora un mondo
di persone che si potrebbero attivare
migliaia di catastrofi potremmo ancora
evitare
la chiave di volta è uscire dalla
comfort zone dell'inattivismo diventare
speranza attiva
Sì perché con la crisi climatica che
avanza o siamo noi che per primi
decidiamo di uscire dalla comfort zone o
molto presto sarà la crisi climatica a
obbligarci a farlo e non lo farà Certo
con delicatezza no lo farà sconquassando
il mondo per come lo conosciamo
dilanando intere società e causando
centinaia di milioni di morti
alla fine la scelta è molto semplice
stare comodi o scomodarsi stare immobili
o agitarsi
e quindi la domanda sorge spontanea
Ma quando si esce dalla comfort zone
come si fa a uscirne e io stessa me lo
sono chiesto più volte
in realtà me lo sono chiesto guardandomi
indietro Quand'è che sono uscita dalla
comfort zone E pensandoci Io mi sono
trovata fuori dalla comfort zone quasi
senza rendermene conto
all'improvviso ero dentro al corteo del
primo sciopero per il clima indetto a
livello globale da fridays for future
era il marzo 2019 e nella mia piccola
città Forlì che le cui strade sono
sempre deserte sempre vuote non c'è mai
un'anima quel giorno
migliaia di persone
diversissime tra loro hanno invaso le
strade Io ricordo ancora così bene
quell'energia quell'energia mi è rimasta
dentro ed è stato proprio in quel
momento che ho preso una decisione molto
spesso siamo portati a pensare che il
mondo non cambia mai allora io lì preso
una decisione
Se il mondo non cambia sarei stata io la
dimostrazione a me stessa che le cose e
le persone possono cambiare
e quindi da quel momento diventai
attivista iniziai a fare attivismo in
fridays for futures e devo dire che il
percorso non è sempre in discesa
l'attivismo è difficile e più si
ascoltano le testimonianze delle persone
maggiormente colpite dalla crisi
climatica più ci si accorge di quanto
sia una questione di giustizia ancor
prima che un tema Scientifico però
grazie all'attivismo si entra anche in
una rete di persone che sono lì a farsi
forza a vicenda e insieme alle quali
lottare per Questa giustizia e si
sperimenta ogni giorno la bellezza di
essere da questa parte della storia
Quindi quando uscire dalla comfort zone
potrei dirvi ora
ma sarebbe una bugia
il momento giusto non esiste il momento
arriva per ogni persona in maniera
diversa quindi mi limiterò semplicemente
a dirvi siate speranza Attiva a modo
vostro in modo unico
ci sono solo due cose da tenere a mente
la prima usate la vostra voce e la
seconda portate un cambiamento a partire
dalla vostra realtà a partire dal vostro
posto di lavoro dai vostri figli dai
vostri amici diffondete consapevolezza e
urgenza e vi capiterà a volte di pensare
Vabbè ma tanto non serve a nulla cosa ci
sto a fare qui tutto inutile è capitato
molto spesso anche a me allora proviamo
a guardarci indietro questo grafico
mostra le ricerche su Google delle
parole cambiamento climatico e emergenza
climatica dal 2017 al 2021
Che cosa sono quelle due punte che cosa
è successo in quei due picchi è successo
questo
e la seconda cosa che Notiamo
prima le linee sono quasi piatte subito
dopo è mare mosso è movimento e quello
significa migliaia di persone che ogni
giorno continuano a tenere alta
l'attenzione sulla crisi climatica e
questo non è successo con l'arrivo di un
magico supereroe che da un giorno
all'altro ci ha salvato No è successo
con l'azione di milioni di persone che
da un giorno all'altro Sono uscite da
quella comfort zone
semplicemente persone persone comuni che
non hanno voluto che quello fosse il
nostro destino si sono opposte e hanno
iniziato a scrivere una storia diversa
c'è una buona notizia chiunque di voi
può essere una di quelle persone
ognuno di voi può diventare la
dimostrazione a se stesso a se stessa
che le persone cambiano e quindi le cose
possono cambiare
c'è anche una cattiva notizia però
il tempo è breve la finestra per agire
si sta chiudendo e noi giovani abbiamo
un tremendo bisogno di speranza
noi giovani non siamo la vostra speranza
voi stessi siete la vostra speranza
quando agite e quindi ora ve lo chiedo
senza mezzi termini agitatevi
[Applauso]